can you believe i have two daughters
around your age kind of scary
i have so much to fill you in on wanna
hear about our new daytime show
love to we're gonna spend an hour every
day celebrating life
oh i'm so excited i could scream
wanna do it with me guys ready
[Music]
hi i'm drew barrymore and i want to
welcome you to episode one
of the making of we really want to bring
you behind the scenes
of what this year-long journey has been
like for us creating this show
it's been exciting it's been scary
it's been challenging
but really at the end of the day it's
been an opportunity
that we want to realize in ways that
exceed
expectations so
i think the best way to do that is to
peel back the curtain
and bring you in because what happens
behind the scenes i think is sometimes
even more important than what you see
out
in front and my whole life has led to
this
and before 2020 we had been proceeding
to make
a daytime talk show i don't think we
were gonna fall
totally pray to pitfalls and trappings
and tropes and cliches but i feel like
the show we were making then
probably does fall in that category and
because
it is our responsibility to meet this
moment
it was the how that was challenging
but it's like the control room's so fun
because you can control fake well you
know i like wall control
oh i feel like halogen or a can light on
top of the head
thank you mitchell so much i also
realized
that with a certain amount of money and
a certain amount of time
you go on this sort of roller coaster
ride to accomplish something
and you're working with new people and
you're all getting to know each other
and
everybody's working you know at a
thousand miles an hour and trying to hit
every cylinder and you're high-fiving
and you're
staying late and you're communicating a
lot i wanted to have a lot of group
meetings so that everyone was on the
same page about what the tone was
as soon as it was over i needed to know
what would get us over a finish line
to make the show we were really gonna
make and then it'll either be
four and five or four and five okay
thank you jerry
jerry
yes the sales tape is an audition it's
been a very unique life
and yet 44 years into it
i feel more alive and more appropriate
for this job than ever
i started working when i was 11 months
old
and i pretty much raised myself
sometimes for worse
sometimes for better my journey in life
hasn't been perfect
but the liberation of that is not having
to pretend to be perfect
i know i'm sorry i know what it's like
to be on the other side so i know
exactly what to do you're also killing
yourself at a thousand miles an hour
um with a group of people not knowing if
it's gonna work
and i've been auditioning my whole life
um i
i associate rejection with a filet o
fish
because every time i didn't get an
audition my mom would take me
for a filleto fish
there's you'd think that would be
demoralizing but it's kind of like
the underdog and you get even more
voracious
about going you know what
we have to make this work and
even if we're just trying to figure this
out and get it done
and we know we'll do things different in
the future
we have got to make this work or there
is no future
i have flown all over the country i've
met with
every single sales team i've met with
most of the station groups so everyone
was calling me congratulations and i
would have to say
it's not a done deal which just was so
awkward but it wasn't we'd all flown
down to miami and armando nunes and
steve ocasio
who had become wonderful
supporters and allies and
champions of this and we had had so many
dinners and so many meetings
about is this going to happen
they ordered a gorgeous bottle of wine
and
that i couldn't drink because once they
said that it was official
i basically was running back and forth
from the bathroom having
one of the biggest panic attacks i've
ever had in my life
i can't really explain it i was joking
with rich cervini
i was like i've just been the lucky
recipient
of um being a part of a talk show and i
can't talk rich
like they're gonna fire me the second
they hired me it's official drew
barrymore will host her
own daytime talk show it's slated to
launch in the fall of next year
who's covering the daytime television
okay girl
we're a full service operation
i have so much work every single day
to figure out and reinvent and re-spark
that fire
and just get down to what is worth being
on the air
what are people gonna respond to and yet
you cannot think anyone's watching
basically said we as cbs you will be
working here this will be your sound
stage
and you will get the privilege of being
in these offices right across the street
and when i walked in the office i just
started to cry
because i totally had my working girl
fantasy
and i just there is something about a
desk
that seems like this
yeah grounding block of concrete
that doesn't weigh me down it anchors me
because my whole life in work has been
so
transient and so liberating and so
like much of what made me like
sort of a fluid person that i am
i think i was always looking for that
anchor
and somehow the metaphor of a desk
really felt like this anchor that i
would
never ever have i am excited
to not play a character
to just get to be me
i'm excited to
take all the things i've learned along
the way
and apply it to this new job where i do
get to be myself
and i know
that i continue to be so lucky and
fortunate
and i'm just i'm never gonna take this
room for granted
i mean cue the carly simon music
this is my office
i this was on the window
[Applause]
so these will be all the producer
offices
this room is really special to me
because
this will be the executive producer's
office who's really our showrunner jason
kind of how i see this process is i
hosted saturday night live for the first
time
in 1982 in new york and
i remember being
in the offices in monday morning you go
in and
you sit in the office it's usually
lauren it's lauren michael's office and
all the cast and the writers and
everybody
sits on the floor and lauren sits at his
desk
and it's a small office it's not bigger
than this
it might even be smaller than this and
everybody piles in and you all feel like
puppies together so when i saw this room
it just made me think of lauren michaels
and
saturday night live really is a training
ground for me
and it's so community and it's so
personal
and like i said you just feel like a
pile of puppies so
this will be our in michael's office
the world health organization says the
risk of the virus expanding worldwide is
now classified as
very high bright lights of hollywood are
dark and the impact
is epic here's cbs's but then that all
changed
and all of a sudden i was positive that
this was not going to happen again in
the second week of march
and i understood that i mean anyone who
can see what was happening in the world
and was going to be like oh
this show isn't going it's like oh my
god shut up and get some perspective are
you kidding me we're in a pandemic
so i felt weird even feeling sad or bad
or trying to mourn something that i
didn't believe was really going to
happen
again as soon as it said like this is
official
we got knocked off our feet again as
everyone did
so then you're kind of working again
like in that sales tape mode like
i think i might be putting so much into
something that may never really happen
but we did and we kept going
that's all special effects or was it
one host one time
i love my kids so much i just want to
squeeze
host a new daytime show
[Music]
it's got my name on it but it's all
about you
[Music]
the show was probably going to end the
office was
closed no one could go anywhere the
coronavirus taking a devastating toll
confirmed cases now top
300 000 really very very strictly adhere
to the guidelines of physical separation
we suggest that if at all possible you
stay at home
coronavirus is exactly like having a
baby
that's exactly what it felt like when
this pandemic started
i'm not gonna lie it wasn't as bad as i
thought it was gonna be
so you just stay home on lockdown trying
to survive
and you're working around the clock
to support and provide life
and i honestly
did not know what i was doing we haven't
even started the show
and
i had a very different vision and
perception
of what we wanted to accomplish with
this and it certainly did not take place
from my home
on a digital platform
i never knew we would be launching a
talk show at the same time no one will
come out to go to a talk show
how do we get around that you'd think
that
that would be so de-incentivizing or
such a bummer it is not
it is what is happening and you deal
with what is happening
we have an advantage in that we're
putting ourselves together
under these circumstances we're not
retrofitting for them so we should take
advantage of that
we should i took a lot of weeks of
working with
everyone on our team so closely on these
brady bunch zooms hopefully i know it's
social distancing time so that is
incredibly challenging we might all be
here in these boxes until eternity
so we always have to have a plan a
and a plan b um it seems like for
everything maybe even a plan c
but we never gave up we did not give in
let's surprise people with emotionality
let's not talk about how important and
intelligent you're gonna feel things in
this show
we will surprise you with like how we
are attacking
everything um and we're also here
in the way that late night shows go hey
you made it through the day man so guess
what we're gonna put you to bed and give
you a reward and a treat
by making you laugh and talk about the
good funny stuff in life i can't
understand why we can't start the day
that way and we will
this is really high stakes for me and i
am scared
i'm scared i've like hit another wall
i know i'll find my way out of it again
i always do
you are not going to be left hanging you
are going to have what you need you're
going to have the environment you need
you're going to
have it where it needs to be whether
it's an alternate look on the set
or something that's moved to another
location it's going to be
where you feel good and creative and
like you can
handle this and feel proud of it
i really want to figure out how to make
this work
i want to connect with people to like
make someone's day lovely like that's
it that's the mission we're all on for
this show
i love zoom i have been saying why are
we not working
from home more hi another day
with a zoom at the top of every hour uh
yeah by the way this is my third zoom
today and it's 9 am here
i feel like more people feel like
they're getting the same amount of work
done
they're having connections with people
they're being prolific
things are getting done and accomplished
talking about where we want to put
cameras and
you know how the set flow works and the
design
aspects of it i am excited about the
people
getting their quality of life by the way
bethany i just thought that was my child
i was like
it was like she was sent here for a
drink
isn't it great if they can do something
for you just even avoiding 30 minutes of
bumper to bumper traffic
i hate traffic there is no question in
my mind
that hal is hot and it is
just full of traffic and
i just go bananas i lose all cool so
somehow like zoom has absolved my life
of all of that and i can wear sweatpants
and i just love it but there is a time
and a place for zoom for sure
it's never gonna replace um
what travel is meant for which is
expanding
our experiences understanding cultures
seeing different things
but for business oh my god
if we ever go back i'm never going back
i don't think we do
i think we've all had a bite of the
apple everybody gets this
and business as usual will never be the
same
we need you every step of the way at
every turn
you have succeeded i loved
so much the page you wrote about how to
shoot
with all the details and particulars
about how we're going to film this
this moment has made me become someone
that i never thought
i could be let alone would be which is
someone
who sought out every technological
advancement
we have this really interesting 2020
mechanism
that i'm really thrilled to introduce
you to
one of a kind virtual audience but do
all virtual
you don't bring a hologram into a
virtual world it's like too many layers
of distance
and technology that don't even look
right i love design and so
i tried to put all of it together into
this new box that was
sort of pretty and shiny and exciting
us being ahead of the game and having a
really elevated visual
architectural design plan and
and technological functionality
uh is going to be crucial how are we
interacting with people
how are we bringing people into this how
does it look
i really think we've got we've got the
seeds of something here
so um you know excited to see what what
we can
build you know a little bit um
bigger you know than what we've
originally talked about and just excited
to see
see what we can come up with
how does our production design now
become instead of you know bleachers for
all these human beings who are not going
to be there
screens i want big screens i've always
loved blade runner when you first see
whatever that place is that
ridley scott created i just think it's
so timeless and cool and you're like
okay screens are the sizes of buildings
this is so compelling so i said we need
big screens
this is the most crude drawing but this
is the screen
where like you know
said person is is this the worst it's
the worst drawing
ever it's not my skill set
and that's me
one thing i don't want to be is like
coming out like a dinosaur
like from my living room so we're going
to figure this out we
do really good work when we're tasked to
think
differently the outcomes sometimes are
like better than if we could have had it
another way
it's so impressive it's just a total
compliment to the team
if 2020 is anything there is a modernity
to this year this historical
game-changing life-altering year
so why shouldn't everything else fall
into line like that why shouldn't
everything take a deep look inside of
itself
and ask questions that
clearly we were not asking before
please welcome drew barrymore i've been
waiting all my life to meet you it's
been a wild ride
can you believe i have two daughters
around your age kind of scary
i have so much to fill you in on want to
hear about our new daytime show
love to we're gonna spend an hour every
day celebrating life
oh i'm so excited i could scream
wanna do it with me guys ready
[Applause]
everything was uncertain and i'm just
like the ones
even the show happening i had to stop
doing that
and just get confident and say this is
happening they say it's still happening
what's it like sitting here right now in
this space
it feels so good which after
five months of everyone being so
forced to be uncomfortable and
re-evaluate everything
and in some ways
have a real rebirth the thing that is
the most important to know
in these times is you don't need a and b
scenario you need a b
and c scenario do you want to shoot this
in another state
do you want to do this from home we're
going to not be in a studio we're going
to be in a loft somewhere
you'll not have a crew you won't have an
audience
we kept hearing every single week
a new revelation of what the pandemic
was narrowing down in our options
so with no options how can you believe
in opportunity but we never gave up
we did not give in even if we have to do
this entire show virtually it should
look like
an expensive like cbs
juggernaut show of like i virtually want
to be there
oh my god
but we have something else to show you
that we were thinking about so this is
sort of an adaptation of what we were
doing last time that we loved
but we were thinking what if the
background is an led screen
and then we can bring in that oh my god
if it's an led screen
we can like soften the background and we
can move things we don't like
rain and we can make it we could sort of
you know we can do whatever we want back
there eventually
well i think that's what they call a
drop the mic moment
well you know again like we still have a
lot of a lot we still have a lot of
figuring out to do
and then certainly had a lot of things i
did want and i did love
and i did want to take with me but every
single thing that we've dealt with
in our path has been this incredible
learning curve
of how we wouldn't do it and when you
figure out
how you wouldn't do something that is
when
the light bulb goes on
oh wow
oh my god
hi it's really nice to dance
it's so beautiful this is so amazing
it's been a little tough as far as
getting things in here but
just a couple curveballs i'm drew thank
you so much for
doing this i'm just trying to figure it
out and i want to do it with everybody
because it's much more fun that way
but i am a student and i don't know
things and i don't
pretend to know things i am learning and
i want to
learn with people then this
is out of a very
insane production design movie this is
like minority report this is
how are you is it okay if i
absolutely yes okay so we just cover we
just cover the floor
and all these years
she really likes it
and so the technological advancement
that we really focused on was something
that
gave me a new
outlook on my own professionalism
because i am very bohemian and old
school and i am not technological and i
am very much a girl
but this moment has made me
become someone that i never thought i
could be
let alone would be which is someone who
sought out every technological
advancement i just want to be
super proactive i know the holographic
like thing is not sustainable for a show
but i feel like
there are times we might want to choose
that battle
hi corona team how's it going in our new
normal oh
good tell me who you are and what you do
i'm drew
and we have a new show coming and here
we are to shoot promos for it
yeah big three marker
we're gonna figure out every single
modern technology
that we can use to not just the show's
advantage
but to modernize television please
welcome drew barrymore
i've been waiting all my life to meet
you it's been a wild ride
can you believe i have two daughters
around your age kind of scary
i have so much to fill you in on want to
hear about our new daytime show
love to we're going to spend an hour
every day celebrating life
oh i'm so excited i could scream
want to do it with me guys ready
i have so much work every single day to
figure out and reinvent
and re-spark that fire and just
get down to what is worth being on the
air
what are people gonna respond to and yet
you cannot think anyone's watching
so why do you do what you do
if you are not doing it thinking about
what other people think
[Music]
as hard as it is at least we don't have
the luxury
or ability to turn away from this we
actually get to be smarter
and better people by learning through
this process
george floyd tony mcdade nina pop and so
many
you know how have we acknowledged that
this is in fact unfair
and that it hurts all of us it hurts our
communities there
are a lot of things happening right now
um a lot of anxieties if you will
um with the race conversation with
coronavirus
i really feel like especially when we're
doing african-american children's books
i love my history i'm working on two
historical books
right now all this comedy that i wanted
to do
is not appropriate anymore and i just
went off social media
and i just started writing and i got
really quiet i just felt like nobody's
voice was really appropriate and
same thing with black lives matter it
was just a
everybody has to be incredibly quiet and
respectful and this is not a time to
really talk about anything but the
subject in front of you and so
through the making of this show
we have been continually tested
on given times
in these crisises and in these moments
and in our culture
where it is time to stop talking and
start listening
and when you're doing a talk show that
can be
very confusing inside but i'm glad
that this has been there because it has
given me a constant north star of
how to find my voice in the most
respectful way
and i do think about what i say and how
i say it but ever more so is that so
crucial
and we always will find our way to
comedy
that's the thing because we need it
comedy is not frivolous comedy is
a medicinal drug-like thing
that we need i have to demote all of my
family members you're like my best
friend now
i think it might be one of the most
transportive
things we have as human beings
when i'm laughing
maybe for that second everything will be
okay maybe it's as simple as that but
that's very powerful
at the same time and maybe it just makes
me know
you know what there's good stuff here
it's all gonna be okay i guess comedy
just makes me feel like it's all gonna
be okay
that's all special effects or was it
one host one time
i love my kids so much i just want to
squeeze
host a new daytime show
[Music]
it's got my name on it but it's all
about you
[Music]
can i talk to you for a second can you
guys shut that door
nice thank you so much
um
um
i am really struggling with just
i
have going on in my head about how much
i dislike myself as a human being
and i just like this is really hard i'm
trying so hard to be on time and
i just i over talk and i
share things that make people
uncomfortable and
then everybody's like oh we need you on
the floor and
just oh i i hate the sound of my own
voice
here's the thing and i'm gonna start a
talk show
in uh you have landed a job
because you have been being you your
entire life and that's what got you this
and now all you're doing is you're
adjusting
for this schedule and this thing is with
maintaining
what why you're here no no no don't deal
with that
okay just say i'm ready and we're going
okay i'm ready and we're going here we
go
because i am full of flaws oh my god i'm
so screwed up i'm so imperfect uh i've
been so broken
so many times in my life
and yet none of that can be an excuse to
stay that way
or to be upset or angry or ever take
that out on
anyone else or to have that be the
reason that you didn't get out of it and
go
to the next place it's it's i just want
to get it right
i just want to get it right i want to do
everything to the best of my ability and
figuring out where all the
compartmentalizing we have your back
we're not
under these circumstances it's a bit
overwhelming for all of us and i can
only imagine
how that feels for drew um
so that day you know was just really the
perfect example of who she is
and what she's about and it's about
honesty
and it's about knowing knowing the
moment and realizing
that we have to live up to this moment
our job is to keep that flow going like
you don't have to keep everything i walk
in here i'm like oh my god
seven segments got this usually it's
like it's overwhelming i'm like
my a.d sarah like stop there's four
stories
here's your stories do yours news first
commercial break get [ __ ] ready for
the next day it's our job to prepare you
for the next
beat you don't have to know everything
you researched it
be in the moment and it's one story at a
time it's one thought at a time
if that thought takes you through drew's
news
she challenges all of us and she
challenged us
big time to say we can't do that show
that we did last year we can't
it's not the world has changed we need
to present things bigger
better we need to take chances and risks
that includes going live that includes
doing virtual interviews
um and really pushing the envelope you
know what else is okay
when you make a mistake you just keep
going
people are so hung up on it has to be
perfect it really doesn't
so that whole sitting stuck in it
feeling sorry for yourself
being stifled you know
i don't know we don't have to be and
i know there are people who have helped
me out of those times so i know i'm
capable of helping others out of those
times
but when you see that you can break
through and get out of them and not
have it be an excuse in life
to be broken then it's just so
liberating
[Music]
available to them
[Music]
5 31 and you're still in the damn
bathroom
katrina
enjoy the go good morning salsa
how are you doing today
what time is it exactly it is 8 41 42.
so i guess that means i'm on time
[Music]
and this is proof that we don't stay
stuck in life
and i'm so omar
yeah umar is here
figure it out it may not look pretty but
we would get there
i have to figure out life or i'm not
going to be as good of a friend as i
demand of myself
you know i don't want to do any of this
in a vacuum i
i since i was seven years old i've been
engaging with people
out on the street and in every venue i
go to my whole
life i have never lived an existence
that isn't interactive with people
go to work i love you too i will go to
work thanks to you
i love you so much i love you so much
but i love bread too but when she came
out with like i love breath
go fix yourself
[Music]
live from new york
um well i think it's been around eight
months
since we were in this office together
you and me omar
and um yeah i had my work and girl
moment
and i had a desk it's here
we're back in the building we get to do
this show
they're letting us do this show
i feel like we're in the fourth quarter
of 2020 and everybody's trying to get in
position
to figure this year out
we all get to be human beings in this
job
and when jason says every friday
going into the weekend go live your life
and bring it back to the show
that is what gives me hope for everyone
being happy in their
job and then hopefully trying to make a
show
that is outward but
very personal all right words of wisdom
to take us
into the night and who has it
i will give you the words of wisdom a
brief moment of clarity says
the wisdom that have carried me through
life i'll make it super quick
never miss a good opportunity and so
this is the word the quote that i picked
out ah that is fantastic
baby you'll move mountains and will you
succeed hello everyone
my words of wisdom are from big boy from
a big boy's neighborhood
when you become successful you're going
to get busy
stay busy but never be too busy
it's never satisfaction without stress
it's how you handle it that makes or
break the situation
put your good heart and your good mind
into it you
you'll overcome the obstacles you've
always had the power my dear you just
had to learn it for yourself
if you're not doing what you love you're
wasting your time don't think outside of
the box
get rid of the box howard say it can't
be done critics
say it shouldn't have been done and
creators say well done we're all brought
here
for a reason
we're doing it this is it thank you for
doing a namaste moment really sweet
every morning when my grandmother would
wake up and she would have an orange for
breakfast
she would stop in the moment before she
would peel the orange
and she would say at this moment this
orange
has not seen the light of day and that's
what our show is right now
it's the orange you get to cherish this
moment where other people haven't seen
that orange that's going to be in the
light of day for everyone to see we get
to treasure this we get to hold this
close to us
and then we get to peel that orange and
everyone else
and i know that i am the kind of person
who believes you have to earn
everything so
i feel lucky that we are able to start
and you know
kind of like my life the rest is up for
me to screw up or not
[Music]
[Music]
i'm waiting for you
[Music]
you